J'ai donc commencé ma quête.
On pensait à l'époque que les télomères protégeaient l'extrémité des chromosomes
pendant la division cellulaire.
C'était vraiment important.
Mais moi, je voulais connaître le but réel des télomères,
et pour cela, il allait m'en falloir un paquet.
C'est alors que mon petit Tetrahymena entre en jeu.
Il possède plein de petits chromosomes linéaires,
environ 20 000.
Donc un tas de télomères.
J'ai alors découvert que les télomères constituent un segment spécifique
porteur d'ADN non-codant à l'extrémité des chromosomes.
Mais un problème apparaît alors.
Nous commençons tous notre vie en étant une unique cellule.
Elle se divise en deux, puis en quatre, puis en huit,
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à devenir les 200 milliards de cellules
qui composent notre corps d'adulte.
Certaines de ces cellules iront jusqu'à se diviser plusieurs milliers de fois.
En réalité, alors que je me tiens là, devant vous,
des cellules se régénèrent à grande vitesse dans tout mon corps,
pour m'aider à me tenir debout, devant vous.
À chaque fois qu'il y a multiplication de cellules, tout l'ADN doit être copié,
du moins, l'ADN codant contenu dans les chromosomes,
qui est porteur d'informations essentielles
pour le bon fonctionnement de nos cellules.
Mes cellules cardiaques permettent à mon cœur de battre à un rythme régulier,
même si là, ce n'est pas vraiment le cas.
Les cellules immunitaires
combattent les bactéries et les virus.
Les cellules cérébrales gardent en mémoire notre premier baiser
et nous permettent d'apprendre au cours de notre vie.
Mais il y a un hic dans la transmission de l'ADN.
C'est juste un de ces faits de la vie.
Chaque fois qu'une cellule se divise et que l'ADN est recopié,
une partie de l'ADN située aux extrémités s'abîme et se raccourcit,
la partie de l'ADN sur les télomères.
Il faut le voir comme
le morceau de plastique qui se trouve aux bouts de vos lacets.
Il protège le lacet, ou le chromosome, pour éviter qu'il ne s'effrite.
Lorsque ce morceau devient trop court, il tombe.
Le télomère abîmé envoie alors une sorte de signal aux cellules :
« L'ADN n'est plus protégé. »
Le signal est envoyé. L'ADN meurt.
Fin de l'histoire.
En réalité, ça ne va pas si vite.
Ce n'est pas la fin de l'histoire,
car la vie n'a pas disparu de la surface de la Terre.
Je me suis demandée :
si une telle usure est inévitable,
comment est-ce que Mère Nature s'assure
que nous pouvons garder des chromosomes intacts ?
Revenons-en à la créature des mares, Tetrahymena.
Dans son cas, les cellules du Tetrahymena ne vieillissent pas, ni ne meurent.
Ses télomères ne sont pas raccourcis par le passage du temps.
Ils peuvent même parfois s'allonger.
Il y a autre chose qui entre en jeu,
quelque chose qui ne se trouve pas dans les manuels scolaires.
Au laboratoire, quand je travaillais avec mon étudiante Carol Greider
(nous avons obtenu un Prix Nobel pour ce travail),
nous avons lancé une série d'expériences
et nous avons découvert quelque chose dans ces cellules.
Elles possèdent une enzyme inédite,
qui permet la reconstitution et l'allongement des télomères
et que l'on appelle la télomérase.
Lorsque nous avons retiré la télomérase de notre créature de mares,
ses télomères ont rapetissé et ont fini par mourir.
C'est donc grâce à la richesse de sa télomérase
que notre créature des mares a le pouvoir de ne pas vieillir.
Voilà un message plein d'espoir
pour nous, humains, de la part de la créature des mares,
parce qu'il faut réaliser
qu'en tant qu'humains, nos télomères se raccourcissent avec le temps.
C'est ce raccourcissement qui nous fait vieillir.
En gros, plus nos télomères sont longs,
mieux on se porte.
Lorsqu'ils sont trop raccourcis,
nous sentons et remarquons alors des signes de vieillissement.
Mes cellules cutanées se meurent
et je commence à remarquer des petites lignes, des rides.
Les cellules capillaires meurent et
des cheveux gris apparaissent.
Les cellules immunitaires meurent
et on a plus de chances de tomber malade.
En réalité, l'intégralité des recherches effectuées ces 20 dernières années
montre bien que l'usure des télomères
augmente nos risques face aux maladies cardio-vasculaires,
à Alzheimer, à certaines formes de cancer ou de diabète, c'est-à-dire
face à des maladies qui tuent la majorité d'entre nous.
Il faut donc y penser.
Que se passe-t-il ?
Cette usure,
on paraît et on se sent plus vieux, ok.
Nos télomères perdent cette guerre contre l'usure plus rapidement.
Pour ceux d'entre nous qui se sentent jeunes plus longtemps,
il se trouve que leurs télomères restent plus longs
pendant plus longtemps,
allongeant leur sentiment de jeunesse
et réduisant les risques qui sont craints de tous
au fil des anniversaires.
D'accord.
Ça semble plutôt simple.
Donc, en considérant que mes télomères soient liés
à la vitesse à laquelle je me sens plus vieille,
si mes télomères peuvent se régénérer grâce à la télomérase,
alors tout ce qu'il faut faire pour inverser les signes et symptômes de l'âge,
c'est de trouver où se procurer une bouteille XXL
de télomérase organique de première qualité, n'est-ce pas ?
Parfait ! Problème résolu !
(Applaudissements)
Pas si vite, désolée.
Malheureusement, on ne peut pas faire ça.
D'accord, mais pourquoi ?
Parce que la génétique humaine nous a appris
qu'en ce qui concerne notre télomérase,
en tant qu'humains, nous sommes sur le fil du rasoir.
Pour faire simple,
en effet, une télomérase améliorée diminue les risques de maladies,
mais elle augmente également les risques de certains cancers redoutables.
Donc même si on pouvait acheter une bouteille XXL de télomérase,
et si ça se trouve, certains sites vendent déjà ce genre de produits contestables,
le problème serait qu'on augmenterait alors les risques de cancer.
Et on ne veut pas de ça.
Mais ne vous inquiétez pas.
Je dois vous avouer que je trouve cela assez drôle, car en ce moment, je pense
que la majorité d'entre nous préférerait devenir une créature des mares.
(Rires)
Il y a quelque chose pour nous,
humains, dans l'histoire et l'entretien des télomères.
Je voudrais clarifier une chose.
Le sujet n'est pas d'allonger notre longévité ou de nous
rendre immortels.
On parle d'espérance de vie sans incapacité.
L'EVSI est le nombre d'années passées dans notre vie
sans être malade, c'est-à-dire en étant en bonne santé, en étant fertile
et en profitant de la vie.
À l'inverse, l'espérance de vie malade
correspond au temps passé à se sentir malade, vieux et mourant.
Se pose alors le vrai problème.
On ne peut absorber de la télomérase,
mais peut-on contrôler la longueur de nos télomères
et améliorer notre bien-être et notre santé
sans augmenter nos risques d'avoir un cancer ?
D'accord ?
Revenons à l'an 2000.
À cette époque, j'avais déjà commencé à étudier de tout petits télomères
depuis de nombreuses années
quand une psychologue du nom d'Elissa Epel est entrée dans mon laboratoire.
Elissa est spécialiste des effets du stress psychologique chronique et grave
sur notre santé mentale et physique.
Et elle se trouvait dans mon laboratoire
qui surplombait ironiquement l'entrée d'une morgue, et...
(Rires)
et elle me posa une question de vie ou de mort.
« Qu'arrive-t-il aux télomères des patients souffrant de stress chronique ? »
me demanda-t-elle.
Elle a fait des études sur les soignants,
notamment sur les mères d'enfants atteints de maladies chroniques,
comme des troubles de l'appareil digestif, l'autisme, et bien d'autres...
Ce groupe choisi était sous un stress psychologique important et persistant.
Et je dois bien l'avouer,
sa question m'a profondément changée.
Pendant tout ce temps, je voyais les télomères
comme de petites structures moléculaires
et les gènes qui contrôlent les télomères.
La question d'Elissa en lien avec son étude sur les soignants
a complètement changé ma vision des télomères.
Je voyais désormais au-delà des gènes et des chromosomes.
Je prenais en compte la vie des personnes que nous étudiions.
J'ai moi-même des enfants
et à ce moment-là,
j'ai vu l'image de ces femmes
s'occupant d'enfants atteints de maladies
difficilement gérables, souvent sans aucune aide.
Et ces femmes ont souvent
l'air abîmées par le temps.
Se pourrait-il alors que leurs télomères soient eux aussi abîmés ?
Ceci a alors déclenché notre curiosité collective.
Pour notre première étude, Elissa a formé un groupe avec ces mères soignantes,
et nous nous sommes posé la question suivante : la longueur de leurs télomères
est-elle proportionnelle au nombre d'années qu'elles ont passé à s'occuper
de leur enfant porteur de maladie chronique ?
Après quatre années,
les résultats sont enfin tombés.
Elissa a alors regardé le premier diagramme
et s'est exclamée en voyant
qu'il y avait bien une tendance qui se révélait.
Il s'agissait de l'évolution dont nous craignions le plus l'existence.
C'était écrit noir sur blanc.
Plus le nombre d'années passées
par une mère à prendre soin de son enfant est important,
peu importe l'âge de la mère,
plus ses télomères sont courts.
De plus, plus la mère considère
sa situation comme étant très stressante,
plus sa télomérase et la longueur de ses télomères diminuent.
Nous avions donc découvert quelque chose d'inédit :
plus une personne est victime de stress chronique, plus ses télomères sont courts.
Cela signifie que son espérance de vie peut être réduite et
qu'elle risque une mort prématurée.
Nos recherches ont permis de déterminer que ce que nous vivons
et la manière dont nous réagissons face à ces événements
agissent sur le bon entretien de nos télomères.
La longueur des télomères n'est donc pas seulement due au passage des années.
La question posée par Elissa
était donc bel et bien une question de vie ou de mort.
Heureusement, nous avons également trouvé de l'espoir parmi ces données.
Pour certaines femmes,
qui se sont également occupées de leurs enfants avec attention pendant des années,
leurs télomères se sont maintenus.
En étudiant ces femmes, nous avons remarqué qu'elles résistaient au stress.
En effet, elles vivaient leur situation
non pas comme une menace constante,
mais comme un défi.
Ceci nous a conduites à une réflexion de la plus haute importance :
nous contrôlons notre manière de vieillir
jusque dans nos cellules.
Notre curiosité initiale est devenue contagieuse.
Des scientifiques spécialisés dans différents domaines
sont venus apporter leur savoir-faire à la recherche sur les télomères,
apportant toutes sortes de résultats.
Nous en sommes à plus de 10 000 articles scientifiques.
Plusieurs études ont confirmé nos premières trouvailles, c'est-à-dire
que le stress chronique est l'ennemi des télomères.
Certaines études révèlent
que nous avons même plus de contrôle sur ce processus de vieillissement
que nous l'avions imaginé.
Par exemple :
l'Université de Californie à Los Angeles a mené une étude
sur des personnes s'occupant de proches atteints de démence sur le long terme
en se penchant sur la capacité d'entretien des télomères de ces personnes.
Les résultats ont montré que cette capacité
était améliorée par la pratique quotidienne d'une certaine forme
de méditation par séance de 12 minutes par jour pendant deux mois.
Notre attitude a son importance.
Si une personne a une attitude pessimiste,
elle vivra une situation stressante comme une menace.
Cela veut dire que si son patron demande à la voir,
elle pensera : « Je vais me faire virer »,
ses vaisseaux se contracteront
et son niveau de cortisol, l'hormone du stress, augmentera
et restera élevé.
Avec le temps, ce taux constamment élevé de cortisol aura
un impact négatif sur la télomérase,
et donc sur les télomères.
D'un autre côté,
si une personne considère une situation stressante comme un défi à relever,
alors le sang irriguera normalement son cœur et son cerveau
et elle ne ressentira qu'un bref pic de cortisol énergisant.
Grâce à cette attitude « à la cool » habituelle,
ses télomères se porteront très bien.
Donc...
Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
Nos télomères se portent bien.
Nous avons le pouvoir de changer ce qu'il se passe
pour nos propres télomères.
Mais notre curiosité a continué de grandir
car nous nous sommes posé la question
de savoir ce qu'il en était des facteurs extérieurs à notre peau.
Peuvent-ils avoir également un impact sur l'entretien de nos télomères ?
Vous voyez, en tant qu'humains, nous sommes des êtres sociaux.
Se pourraient-ils alors que nos télomères soient aussi sociaux que nous ?
Les résultats sont surprenants.
Dès le plus jeune âge,
la négligence émotionnelle, l'exposition à la violence,
le harcèlement et le racisme
ont un impact sur nos télomères et les effets se ressentent sur le long terme.
Quel serait l'impact sur des enfants
ayant longtemps vécu en zone de guerre ?
Les personnes qui ne font pas confiance
à leurs voisins et ne se sentent pas en sécurité dans leur quartier
ont des télomères plus courts.
Notre lieu de résidence a donc un impact sur nos télomères.
A l'inverse,
des communautés soudées, un mariage qui dure depuis des années
ou des amitiés de toute une vie
améliorent l'entretien de nos télomères.
Qu'est-ce que cela veut dire ?
Cela signifie que je peux à la fois avoir un impact sur mes télomères,
mais aussi sur les vôtres.
La science des télomères nous indique à quel point nous sommes connectés.
Mais je reste curieuse.
Je me demande quel héritage
est-ce que nous allons laisser
aux générations à venir ?
Allons-nous investir
dans la prochaine femme ou le prochain homme
qui se penchera sur un microscope pour identifier une nouvelle petite bête,
une nouvelle créature des mares,
et qui s'intéressera à un problème que l'on ne se pose pas aujourd'hui ?
Cela pourrait être un problème à l'échelle mondiale.
Et maintenant, peut être que vous êtes curieux à propos de vous-même.
Vous savez comment protéger vos télomères,
alors qu'allez-vous faire maintenant
que vous avez des décennies à vivre en bonne santé ?
Maintenant que vous pouvez avoir un impact sur les télomères des autres,
vous demandez-vous
comment vous allez faire la différence ?
Maintenant que vous avez vu que la curiosité pouvait changer le monde,
comment allez-vous vous assurer que le monde investisse dans la curiosité
pour le bien des générations futures ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)